[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتشر الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
واشنطن توسع قائمه العقوبات المرتبطه
بروسيا لتشمل 120 فردا وكيا في 20 دوله
وسط حديث عن هجوم اوكراني المرتقب ومخاوف
من تعبئه جديده بروسيا موسكو وكيف تشددان
قواعد التجنيد
باريس تؤكد ان التحالف مع واشنطن لا يعني
التبعيه لها وتتهم الجمهوريين باستخدام
تايوان للضغط على الصين
الامم المتحده توثق غرق اكثر من 441
مهاجرا في البحر المتوسط منذ مطلع العام
[موسيقى]
وصلت مؤقتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
والساعه الولايات المتحده قائمتها السوداء
ضد روسيا بسبب محاوله التحايل على
العقوبات الغربيه وقال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
ان قراراته واشنطن الحاليه تنطبق على اكثر
من 120 منظمه وفردا في اكثر من عشرين دوله
مؤكدا ان الاجراءات التقليديه الجديده قد
تم اتخاذها بحق ما يدعمون العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه كما تطال اولئك الذين
يساعدون في التحايل على العقوبات الغربيه
المفروضه سابقا على روسيا
اذا الولايات المتحده تواصل مساعيها في
تجديد خناقها على روسيا بهذا الخصوص اتهمت
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه 4 كيانات على
الاقل مقرها تركيا ينظر اليها على انها
تتهرب من العقوبات وضوابط التصدير
المفروضه على روسيا واشار مسؤول في
الاداره الامريكيه ان التحرك الامريكي هو
تحذير لفرض ضوابط على الصادرات التركيه
وهو ما يعد اكبر اجراء في تركيا منذ بدء
الحرب كما اكد على ان الولايات المتحده
استهدفت كيانات مقرها تركيا في قطاعات
بحريه وتجاريه مرتبطه بروسيا في المقام
الاول
[موسيقى]
ولا حديث في كواليس الحرب الاوكرانيه سوى
عن الهجوم المضاد المرتقب الكياف فروسيا
واوكرانيا معا تعدان العده
وترتبان صفوفهما للمعركه المرتقبه اخر
القرارات المتخذه في هذا الباب تشديد كل
من روسيا واوكرانيا قواعد التجنيد
الالزامي ورغبه منها في تكثيف عمليه
التجنيد وافقت على تشريع يسمح لمراكز
التجنيد بارسال الاستدعاءات الى اي مكان
في البلاد وليس فقط في العناوين المسجله
للذين يتم استدعائهم وياتي هذا القرار على
خلفيه عدم وصول العديد من الاستدعاءات
لاصحابها بسبب حركه الهجره الداخليه التي
اعقبت الحرب وكانت كياف قد اصدرت قرارا
يمنع الرجال الذين تتراوح اعمارهم بين 18
و60 عاما من مغادره البلاد منذ بدايه
العمليه العسكريه قبل الزياده من عام
اما في روسيا فقد سارع البرلمان الى اقرار
تشريعات اكثر صرامه فالتشريع الجديد يصعب
على الروس التهرب من التجنيد حيث لم يعد
واجبا تسليم اختارات التجنيد الى اصحابها
مباشره بل يمكن ارسالها الكترونيا عبر
بوابات الخدمه العامه الحكوميه ولا يسمح
للمجندين الذين ارسلت اليهم اشعارات
الكترونيه بمغادره البلاد حيث سيطلب منهم
التوجه الى المفوضي المفوضيه العسكريه في
غضون 20 يوما من تاريخ التسلم او التعرض
لعقوبه شديده
موسكو من جهتها بادرت الى التاكيد على ان
القرار ياتي بهدف تسهيل عمليه التجنيد
بهذا الخصوص قال المتحدث باسم الرئاسه
الروسيه ان التغييرات تهدف الى تحسين نظام
التسجيل العسكري ولا علاقه لها بالتعبئه
وياتي ذلك وسط مخاوف من تعبئه جديده في
روسيا
معنى من كييف الدبلوماسيه السابقه
اهلا بكم معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
بدايه في اي اطار يمكن وضع تجديد اجراءات
التجنيد في كل من روسيا واوكرانيا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته عليكم
نعم الان في اوكرانيا موجود عمليه التعبيه
الجزئيه حتى تعبيته العمل بصفه عامه وهذا
منطقي بصراحه وخاصه في
هجوم مضاد قوات المسلحه اوكرانيا
المونتاجر في اقرب وجهور من المعروف
بانكرانيا تمنع خروج خارج اوكرانيا لرجال
من بدائره ولكن بصراحه الان موجود
لطلاب لخروج للدراسه خارج اوكرانيا ولكن
بصفه عامه اكيد عند اوكرانيا
وكمان كوادر عسكريه للاسفه شديده نعم طيب
ولكن بالنسبه للروس هل نحن امام تعبئه
جديده تعتقد في انتظار او يعني تحضيرا لما
يعتقد انها هجوم مضاد اوكراني لاستعاده
المناطق التي سيطرت عليها روسيا
بصراحه نعم نحن كمان سمعنا بان روسيا الان
سوف هي تحقق تعبيه العامه في ضوء هجوم
مضادات وقوات مصالحه ولكن بصراحه هذا لن
يصعد لروسيا الان بصراحه هذا
المشاهده حرب المدافع وبهذا السبب كمان
بالمناسبه هذا الحرب
متطوره روسيا متخالفه وتكنولوجيا جدا
بمقارنه مع كل هذا المعادلات عسكريه التي
اوكرانيا حاصله من غرب وخاصه من امريكا
بالمناسبه اليوم نحن سميعنا كمان خبر جميل
من الممكن اوكرانيا سوف تحصل على الدبابات
الابرمس من امريكا في الصيف القادم طيب
سنرى تاثير هذه الاسلحه الجديده التي
تتحدث عنها وساعود اليك في زاويه اخرى وهي
زاويه التطورات المعارك في باخمه مشاهدينا
حيث نفى الجيش
الاوكراني مزاعم قوات فاجنر الروسيه التي
تحدثنا عنها بالامس في اخبار الساعه بانها
استولت على اكثر من 80% من مدينه باخمت
مشيرا الى ان الجيش استعاد السيطره على
اكثر من 20% في شرق المدينه
ما رايك يعني في هذا التضارب في التصريحات
يعني
السيطره على 80% على باخمت من قبل الروس
واليوم هذا النفي الاوكراني برايك من يقول
الحقيقه
بان تقريبا منذ شهرين افادا
رئيس مجموعه
ثلاثه ايام
مجموعه
ولكن ماده اكثر من
شهرين
ومازال موجود صمود هالكوات مصالحه بصفه
عمل لنتذاكر وكمان بين روسيا تقاتل
تقريبا ثمانيه
هو واحد ينبغي ادراك بان هدف عند قوات
مصالحه اوكرانيه هذا استنزاف الروس على
ماكسيموم في هذه المنطقه وبصراحه انا
اعتقد بان هذه سياسه الاستنزاف هي ناجحه
عند قوات مصالحه نعم ولكن سيد عمليا
الاوكرانيون في وضع دفاعي منذ فتره طويله
هناك في باخمت ما الذي يدفعك الى الاعتقاد
بانه يمكن ان يكون هناك بالفعل يمكن
الحديث عن انكفاء للقوات الروسيه بصراحه
موجوده عمليه تجديد دفاعيه ليس فقط وكما
في جنوب اوكرانيا بصراحه نحن ننتظر هجوم
مضادات قوات المسلحه تقريبا
ولكن موجود صمود هاي القوات مصالحه
اوكرانيا هدف اساسي كما نقول هذا
الاستنزاف في هذا المنطقه واحد اوكرانيا
تحقق تعزيز قواتها وما زال اوكرانيا في
انتظار من غرب مواعظات عسكريه ومنها
ضبابات ثقيله وبالمناسبه للاسف الشديد
لاوكرانيا لم تحصل في اقرب وقت على
مقتلاته هذه مقاتلات هامه جدا لاوكرانيا
في هجوم مضادات القوات مصالحه لان
اوكرانيا تحتاج الدعم من الجو بمقاتلات
امريكا رافضت تقديم لي اوكرانيا في اقرب
الوقت هذه المقاتلات وللاسفه شديده اكيد
خسائر ارواح سوف تكون اكثر من الممكن بسبب
عدم الحصول على كل هذا
نطلب من غرب اي اسلحه متطوره لان اوكرانيا
من اجل السلام فعلنا معاصره شكرا جزيلا لك
من كيف
[موسيقى]
لغه الحرب لا تقتصر فقط على تحقيق
الانتصارات على ارض الميدان بل تمتد الى
استعراض العضلات ايضا فيما يعرف بالحرب
النفسيه في هذا السياق اعلنت روسيا اجراء
تجربه ناجحه لاطلاق صاروخ باليستي عابر
للقارات وصفته بالمتقدم اتاتي هذه التجربه
الصاروخيه بعد اسابيع من تعليق روسيا
مشاركتها في اخر اتفاق للحد من الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه مع الولايات المتحده هذا
وكشفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الصاروخ
انطلق من مقاطعه استرخان الروسيه ونجح في
ضرب هدف وهمي في ميدان للتدريب بكازاخستان
ولم تحدد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه دائما نوع
الصاروخ المستخدم لكنها ذكرت ان الهدف من
هذه التجربه هو اختبار معدات قتاليه
متطوره لصواريخ باليستيا عابره للقارات
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه في ظل توتر
متصاعد مع تايوان الرئيس الصيني يوعز
بتعزيز تدريبات الجيش
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد عاصفه الوثائق السريه
المسربه لم تهدا بعد واصداؤها لا تزال
تصلح في العديد من بقاع العالم وبعيدا عن
الجدال المصارعه حول كيفيه التسريب فان
النقاش يدور ايضا حول احتماليه ان يكون
التسريب مجرد مناوره في اطار ما يسمى بحرب
المعلومات في اخر ردود الفعل على هذه
التسريبات اعتبرت موسكو ان الوثائق
الامريكيه المسربه قد تدخل ضمن حمله تضليل
من جانب الولايات المتحده بهدف خداع روسيا
وعلق نائب وزير الخارجيه
على الموضوع قائلا ان تسريب قد يكون مزيفا
ومتعمدا من جانب واشنطن من جهته قال
المتحدث باسم الكرملين روسيا لا تعرف في
هذه المرحله مدى صحه هذه الوثائق
كيف بدورها حاولت عدم اعاره اهتمام كبير
لهذه الوثائق حيث صرح وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني
ان الوثائق المسربه ما هي الا مزيج من
الصدق والكذب على حد قوله لافتا الى انها
صبت لمصلحه روسيا وحلفائها كما نفى
ريزينيكوف صحه وجود قوات من حلف النيتو في
اوكرانيا كما اشارت الى ذلك الوثائق
بدورها اعترضت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
على دقه المعلومات الوارده في الوثائق
المسربه بعدما اشارت احداها الى ان نحو
خمسين من افراد القوات الخاصه البريطانيه
متواجده حاليا في اوكرانيا
والى ذلك قال السفير الامريكي في بودابست
ان الولايات المتحده لديها مخاوف بشان حرص
الحكومه المجريه المستمر على تعزيز
العلاقات مع روسيا ياتي ذلك بعد اعلان
واشنطن فرض عقوبات على ثلاثه مسؤولين كبار
في بنك الاستثمار الدولي في المجر وكانت
وثيقه امريكيه سريه مسربه ذكرت ان المجر
تخشى من تدخل امريكا في انتخاباتها كما
اعتبر رئيس الوزراء المجري فيكتور اوربان
امريكا بانها واحده من اكبر ثلاثه اعداء
لحزبه
[موسيقى]
في اخر تطورات قضيه تصريحات الرئيس
الفرنسي التي دعا فيها اوروبا الى تخفيف
التبعيه للولايات المتحده قال دبلوماسي
الفرنسي كبير ان القياده الجمهوريه
للكونغرس الامريكي تستخدم تايوان في الضغط
على الصين واضاف الدبلوماسي الفرنسي الذي
طلب عدم الكشف عن هويته ان اوروبا لا ولن
تنجر الى هذا الصراع وصرح ذاته المتحدث ان
الرئيس الفرنسي لن يتراجع عن تعليقاته
التي حث فيها الاتحاد الاوروبي على تقليل
الاعتماد على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
دبلوماسي فاشل هكذا هجمت احدى ابرز الصحف
الفرنسيه رئيس البلاد ايمانويل ماكرون عقب
تصريحات اثارت جدلا داخليا وخارجيا صحيفه
ليباراسيون وصفت محاوله ماكرون للدفاع عن
الاستقلال الاستراتيجي الاوروبي بالخرقاء
وذهبت الى ان الرئيس يبدو راضيا عن بكين
في الملف التايواني ماكرون رفض في تصريحات
له
لصحيفتيكول الامريكيه وصحيفه ليزيكول
الفرنسيه عقب زيارته للصين اي تبعيه
للولايات المتحده او الصين حول تايوان
الرئيس الفرنسي عاد وجدد موقفه بعد ايام
من هولندا
اصر على دوري الاستقلاليه الاستراتيجيه ان
تكون حليفا ليس معناه ان تكون تابعا
ماكرون اكد ايضا على ضروره تقليل الاعتماد
على واشنطن لا سيما في مجال الامن وصناعه
العسكريه والدولار ايضا
نبره مكرونيه حاده تجاه واشنطن استقبلها
مسؤولون امريكي بلغه دبلوماسيه غير ان
اصواتا لم تتردد في انتقاد موقف ماكرون
دونالد ترامب مثلا حاضر
لدينا هذا العالم المجنون الذي ينفجر في
كل مكان والولايات المتحده ليس لها راي
على الاطلاق قلت لنفسي حسنا ماكرون كان
صديقا لي ورايته يلاحق ويزور بكين ماكرون
ابدا سفه لما بدا من الترامب واعتبر ان
ذلك يساعد الموقف الرئاسه الفرنسيه اشارت
الى ان ترامب اول من التمس العذره للصين
حين كان رئيسا لكن ذلك لم يمنع من انتقاد
ماكرون صحيفه
وصفت موقفه بالفشل كذلك صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز اعتبرت الزياره تقويضا للجهود
الامريكيه الراميه لاحتوائ نفوذ النظام
الاستبدادي بقياده الرئيس الصيني على حد
قولها
ومع تصاعد التوتر بين الصين وتايوان اذا
مشاهدينا دعا الرئيس الصيني القوات
المسلحه الى تعزيز التدريب العسكري من اجل
قتال فعلي واكد الرئيس الصيني ان بلاده
ستدافع بحزم عن سلامتها الاقليميه والحدود
البحريه وستسعى جاهده لتحقيق الاستقرار في
المنطقه واشار الى ان الصين ستعمل على
ضمان الاستجابه للتحديات المعقده وفي
الوقت المناسب
[موسيقى]
استقبل نائب وزير الخارجيه السعوديه اوليد
الخريجي وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل
المقداد وذلك لدى وصوله الى مطار الملك
عبد العزيز في مدينه جده واوضحت الخارجيه
السعوديه ان المقداد يزور المملكه بدعوه
من وزير الخارجيه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
ومن المقرر عقد جلسه مباحثات ثنائيه
تتناول جهود المبذوله للوصول الى حل سياسي
للازمه السوريه يحافظ على وحده سوريا
وامنها واستقرارها وتسهيل عوده اللاجئين
السوريين الى وطنهم وتامين وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه للمناطق المتضرره في سوريا
في الاثناء بحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان خلال اتصال هاتفي مع
المبعوث الاممي الى سوريا
والجهود الامميه في هذا الصدد وذكرت وكاله
الانباء السعوديه ان الوزير اكد حرص
المملكه على بدل كافه الجهود للتواصل الى
حل سياسي مشددا على ضروره ان يحافظ الحل
على وحده سوريا وامنها واستقرارها
وانتماءها العربي وان يحقق الخير والنماء
لشعبها الشقيق
ونبقى في السعوديه اذا حيث اعلن المتحدث
باسم وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني عن وصول وفد ايراني الى المملكه
لاتخاذ التدريبات اللازمه لفتح السفاره
ايران في الرياض وقنصليتها في جده كنعان
اوضح ايضا في تصريحات النشرات وسائل وسائل
الاعلام ان الوفد سيبحث في السعوديه
استئناف نشاط الممثليه الايرانيه الدائمه
في منظمه التعاون الاسلامي مشيرا الى ان
طهران تسعى لفتح بعثاتها في السعوديه
واستئناف نشاطها قبل موسم الحج هذا
وسيغادر الوفد الفني السعودي الذي وصل الى
ايراني يوم السبت الماضي سيغادر متوجها
الى مشهد غدا لبحث اعاده فتح القنصليه
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الولايات
المتحده تشدد قواعد مكافحه التلوث في
السيارات للترويج للمركبات الكهربائيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مكتبه الكتب والمخطوطات
النادره بالمسجد النبوي تزهر بالكثير من
المؤلفات بشتى المجالات الشرعيه والعلميه
التي يعود تاريخ البعض منها الى السادس من
الهجره السادس الهجريه يعني اذ يحرص
الباحثون زوار المسجد على زياره المكتبه
للتعرف على المخطوطات الاسلاميه النادره
والمراجع الموثوقه
[موسيقى]
تتنفس هذه الارفف المزدحمه بالكتب النادره
التاريخ الاسلاميه والعلوم الشرعيه وشتى
المجالات العلميه المختلفه والتي يحتضنها
المسجد النبوي ويعود تاريخ البعض منها الى
عده قرون عدد الكتب يزيد عن 7000 كتاب
جميعها مرقمنه يستطيع ان يستفيد منها
الباحث هو الزائر اما عن طريق الاطلاع او
عن طريق
الرقمنه بحيث انه يستطيع ان يحصل على نسخه
من هذه الكتاب اقدم هذه الكتب عمره ما
يقارب 200 سنه يحرص الباحثون وزوار المسجد
النبوي على التردد على هذه المكتبه للتزود
بالمعلومات والمراجع الموثوقه لاستكمال
ابحاثهم والتزود بالمعرفه ممكن تحصل في
هذه الاداره على كتب وتجدها هنا غير
موجوده في المكتبات الاخرى لان اسمها
الكتب النادره وهي الان هنا محفوظه معتنى
بها ولها برامج
[موسيقى]
ترميم وبرامج تعقيم
في الجانب الاخر قسم خاص بالمخطوطات
الاسلاميه القديمه والثمينه التي يرجع
تاريخها الى القرن السادس الهجري ويقصد
بالمخطوطات الاسلاميه التراث الاسلامي
المكتوب بخط اليد وقد عنيى المسلمون
بالمخطوطات عنايه كبيره لكونها السبيل
الوحيده للحفاظ على ما انتجه العقل
الاسلامي يوجد في اداره المخطوطات اكثر من
4000 مخطوط اصلي واكثر من 500 مصحف مخطوط
اصلي يعتنى فيها وتعرض لي الزوار
والباحثين وطلاب العلم يشهدوا المسجد
النبوي منذ مطلع شهر رمضان اعدادا مليونيه
بعد التشغيل بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه دون
قيود مقدمه كافه الخدمات بمختلف اشكالها
للتسهيل على المصلين والزوار من المسجد
النبوي سلطان السلمي العربيه
اعلنت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين عن استعداد كافه
مواردها البشريه ومعدتها التشغيليه
لتيسير التيسير على قاصدي المسجد الحرام
اثناء ادائهم للمناسك والصلوات بكل سكينه
واطمئنان حيث سيشهد الحرم المكي كثافه
كبيره خاصه في العشر الاواخر من رمضان هذا
ووصل عدد المصلين والمعتمرين الى اكثر من
الف مصلل ومعتمر يوميا منذ بدايه رمضان
950 الف معتمر ومصلن اذا في اليوم الواحد
في الحرم المكي
طيب نذهب الى مكه المكرمه معنا من هناك
مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم اسامه اهلا بك
معنا هل بدات تستشعر ان هناك اعداد اكبر
بدات تصل في العشر الاواخر مقارنه بالايام
الاولى من رمضان اسامه
اهلا وسهلا صهيب تحيه طيبه لك وللجميع
المشاهدين العربيه انقل لكم الصوت والصور
اليوم من اعلى نقاط الحرم المكي الشريف
وبالتحديد من احدى اسطح التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه نعم حديثنا اليوم عن هذه الاعداد
الغفيره التي تاتي اليوم الى الحرم المكي
الشريف اعلنت الرئاسه في تصريح سابق عن
وصول اكثر من 950 الف مصل ومعتمر في اليوم
الواحد ما يقارب الى يومنا هذا حوالي 20
مليون مصلي ومعتمر اذا نترك لكم الان عبر
الكاميرا العربيه هذه الصوره من ساحات
المسجد الحرام وايضا اسطوحه التوسعه
السعوديه وايضا نشهد ايضا الحركه المروريه
وتيسير حركه مروريه المتواجده هنا نعم اذا
نشهد اليوم بالتاكيد توافد الكثير من
الزوار والمعتمرين وقاصدي بيت الله الحرام
بشكل اكبر من الايام السابقه طبعا العشر
الاواخر بالتاكيد لها مكانتها وبالتالي كل
زائر ومعتمد يحرص ان يؤدي مناسك العمره
وايضا الصلاه في المسجد الحرام خصوصا بعد
اداء صلاه القيام من الامس نتحدث اليوم
ايضا عن
هذه الصور التي تشاهدون الان بعد انتهاء
صلاه التراويح بساعه تقريبا وما زالت هذه
الاعداد تملا الساحات وايضا نشهد توافد
الكثير من الزوار المعتمرين لان يؤدوا
مناسك العمره او ايضا يؤدوا صلاه القيام
نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن الخدمات المقدمه بعد
استكمال اعمال تهيئه
يعني هذا الموسم يشهد اقبالا كبيرا واعداد
كبيره كما تفضلت عشرين مليون زائر ومعتمر
زارو الحرم في شهر رمضان حتى الان ما هي
الخدمات الجديده التي تقدمها السلطات
السعوديه امام هذه الاعداد الكبيره
نعم صحيح بدايه السلطات السعوديه قدمت كل
الدعم للزوار المعتمرين لان يعيشوا هذه
التجربه بشكل مثالي وايضا لان يؤدوا
مناسكهم بكل يسر وسهوله وطمانينه تحدث
اليوم عن الاعمال الموجوده والخدمات
المقدمه لضيوف الرحمن اكثر من 30 مليون
لتر من سقيا زمزم تم استهلاكها في العشرين
اليوم الماضيه وايضا ستزيد هذه الاعداد في
الايام القادمه اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين
وخمسمائه الف مستفيد اليوم من الخدمات
التوعويه والتطوعيه والانسانيه والميدانيه
هنا في الحرم المكي الشريف هذه الصوره
ايضا للساحات بامتلائها بالزوار وقاص في
بيت الله الحرام نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن
الخدمات التطوعيه والانسانيه والعلاجيه
التي تقدمها الجهات الطبيه المتواجده هنا
بمباشرته اكثر من عشره الاف حاله متواجده
وجود ايضا اكثر من 25 الف متطوع ليباشروا
الحالات المتواجده ايضا وجود المعدات
والادوات التي تهيئ لقاصد بيت الله الحرام
ان يعيش بكل يسر وطمانينه ايضا نتحدث
اليوم بحديث هذه الاعداد المليونيه عن خطه
التفويج واداره الحشود هناك قوه امنيه
متواجده في كل مداخل الحرم المكي الشريف
وايضا في ساحات المسجد الحرام ليدخلوا
ويخرجوا الزوار المعتمرين بكل يسر
وطمانينه لكي لا يحدث هناك تدافع طبعا
شهدنا هذه الحركه من بدايه شهر رمضان
المبارك بالخطه التشغيليه الاولى للعشره
ايام الاولى والخطه التشغيليه الثانيه
للعشره ايام الثانيه ونبدا الان باستكمال
الخطه التشغيليه الثالثه ونشهد الان
الوصول المباشر وايضا عدم وجود اي حالات
اختناق او تزاحمات في المداخل والمخارج
هناك ايضا اكثر من 12 باب تم تخصيصها
للصلاه والعمره فقط عن بقيه الخدمات
المتواجده ايضا حتى نتحدث اليوم صهيب عن
خدمات حتى المقدمه لدول احتياجات الخاصه
وايضا المصليات المخصصه لهم وحتى دورات
المياه المخصصه لهم بالتاكيد هذه الخدمات
التي تحددها اليوم الجهات دخول وخروج بكل
يسر كما نتابع حقيقه اسامه يعطيك الصحه
انت وفريق العربيه المتواجد الحقيقه في
الحرم المكي الش ريف طبعا مع ايام شهر
رمضان ومع الصيام ومع الاعداد الكبيره
الحقيقه مشقه كبيره في هذه التغطيه يعطيكم
الصحه جميعا شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه الصوره
الحيه مباشره اذا من المسجد الحرام اسامه
القاسم
[موسيقى]
شادينا الكرام اذا نتابع معكم هذه الاخبار
العاجله عن الخارجيه السعوديه طبعا بعد
زياره وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد
الى الرياض لاول مره اول زياره لوزير
خارجيه سوري منذ 11 عاما الخارجيه
السعوديه تقول ان المباحثات السعوديه
السوريه في جده ناقشت حلا سياسيا يحافظ
على وحده سوريا اذن كما نتابع معكم اذن
المباحثات السعوديه السوريه كانت ذات
اهميه حول طبعا وصول حل الصعوبات
الانسانيه في سوريا كذلك طبعا هذا ايضا عن
هذا الخبر العاجل اذا كذلك خبر عاجل ورد
قبل قليل ولكن بخصوص السودان حيث اعلنت
قوتها الدعم السريع في السودان ان وجودها
بالولايه الشماليه هو لتاديه الواجب
والتنسيق مع الجيش مشيره الى انها لا تقوم
باي عمليه عسكريه باتجاه مطار مروي
وقبل ذلك افادت مصادر العربيه في السودان
ان منطقه مروي شهد التوترا بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني ووفقا لمصادر
العربيه فان قوه قوامها اكثر من 100 سياره
من قوات الدعم السريع وصلت الى مدينه مروي
في الولايه الشماليه واوضحت المصادر ان
قوات الجيش رفضت تمركز قوات الدعم السريع
في المنطقه والتي كانت قد بررت انتشارها
هناك بامتلاك ارض زراعيه بالقرب من مطار
مروي اشارت مصادر العربيه الى ان الدعم
السريع كان قد بدا في مطلع شهر رمضان
وعبر احد الاعيان بالمنطقه في بناء سور
ومرافق في الارض المحاذيه للمطر
في سياق قله المنظمات الدوليه للهجره
التابعه للامم المتحده ان اكثر من 400
مهاجر ولاجئ غرقوا في الاشهر الاولى من
عام 2023 نتحدث اذا عن سياق الهجره غير
الشرعيه الان حيث اثناء محاولتهم عبور
البحر المتوسط من شمال افريقيا الى اوروبا
وهو اكبر عدد من القتلى في فتره ثلاثه
اشهر خلال السنوات الست الماضيه المنظمه
وثقت
441 حاله وفاه بين يناير كانون الثاني
ومارس اذار على طريق الهجره الاكثر تسجيلا
لحالات الوفاه في العالم وقالت ان العدد
الفعلي اكبر من هذا على الارجح لافته الى
ان نصف هذه الوفيات مرتبط بالتاخر في جهود
الانقاذ التي تقودها الدول
[موسيقى]
الانبعاثات الملوثه قد تسرع من انتشار
السيارات الكهربائيه في الولايات المتحده
هذا ما تطمح اليه الحكومه الامريكيه التي
ادخلت معايير اكثر صرامه بشان انبعاثات
السيارات وتتمثل المعايير في فرض قيود على
مصانع السيارات لخفض معدل الانبعاثات
الملوثه من السيارات فضلا عن تشجيعهم على
تصنيع السيارات الكهربائيه
وترمي الحكومه الامريكيه ايضا من خلال هذا
القرار للتقليل من استيراد النفط وخفض
نفقات السائقين السيارات على الوقود هذا
ووضعت الحكومه الامريكيه هدفا جديدا يتمثل
في رفع مبيعات السيارات الكهربائيه الى
نسبه 67% من مجموع السيارات المباعه في
البلاد بحلول عام 2032
وتعرف سوق السيارات الكهربائيه في
الولايات المتحده اقبالا ضعيفا حيث شكلت
فقط 5.8 بالمئه من مجموع السيارات المباعه
في البلاد في عام 2022
[موسيقى]
ايضا مشاهدينا المزيد من الاخبار العاجله
نقلا عن الخارجيه السعوديه اذا المباحثات
مع سوريا ناقشت تحقيق تسويه بسوريا
لعودتها الى محيطها العربي تضيف الخارجيه
السعوديه كذلك ان المباحثات مع الجانب
السوري ناقشت خطوات تحقيق تسويه شامله في
سوريا كذلك الخارجيه السعوديه تقول ان
المباحثات السعوديه السوريه ناقشت سبل
ايصال المساعدات الى سوريا اذا كما ذكرنا
ايضا وحل الصعوبات الانسانيه في سوريا
طبعا مشاهدينا هذه المواقف السعوديه
الجديده التي عبرت عنها الخارجيه السعوديه
في اعقاب اذن الزياره الاولى لوزير
الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد الى جده
واجراهم محادثات هناك مع الجانب السعودي
طبعا بعد في اول زياره لوزير سوري منذ 11
عاما الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه اخبار
الساعه شكرا على المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات